[Music]
on this Sunday night bear attack in bamp
a Grizzly kills two people in Canada's
most popular National Park bear attacks
are extremely unusual well officials in
BC report a huge spike in Black Bear
encounters getting a raise six provinces
increase their minimum wage but can it
keep up with the cost of living funding
fatigue political moves in the US and
Europe suggest military support for
Ukraine is
slipping plus a whole new ball game it
wasn't the way we wanted to get in but
we're in the Bluejays punch their ticket
to the
playoffs global national with faren
Asser reporting tonight Jeff
simple good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin with tragedy at this
country's most popular National Park
after a deadly grizzly bear attack it
happened Friday night at bamp National
Park in Alberta authorities received an
alert from a GPS device indicating a
bear attack they rushed to the location
to find two people dead Wildlife
officials also encountered a bear
displaying aggressive behavior that
animal was then euthanized Carolyn Curry
de Castillo is in bam National Park
tonight so Carolyn what do we know so
far Jeff there's stunning scenery out
here on the far East End of B national
park on the Eastern slopes of the
Rockies but it's also grizzly bear
country the yaha tinda Ranch area west
of sundry is popular with horseback
Riders and hikers it was around 8 on
Saturday evening that Parks Canada
dispatch got a GPS device alert about a
be attack in the Red Deer River Valley
area west of yaha tinda Ranch now the
weather was bad so a helicopter couldn't
go in so a response team from Parks
Canada traveled through the night by
ground and they got there at around 1:00
in the morning that's where they found
two deceased people now while they were
in the area the response team
encountered a grizzly bear they say was
displaying aggressive behavior and they
euthanized it bear attacks are extremely
unusual it does not happen very often at
all most of most likely bears want to
stay away from humans and not have an
encounter with us uh so something to
provoke this was likely I give my
condolences to the family and the
friends but likely something the humans
did that provoked the attack now be
experts say any number of things could
have triggered that response in a bear
including dogs being startled or
defending a food source there's an
estimated 900 grizzly bears in Alberta
Jeff all right Carolyn Curry de Castillo
in ban thanks Carolyn in BC bear
sightings are skyrocketing that
province's conservation officers say
they received twice as many calls about
bare Encounters this summer compared to
what they typically see as Paul Johnson
reports the situation is also leading to
an alarming spike in bears being put
down
it was a site that was hard to forget a
black bear roaming the high density
parts of Langley near Willowbrook Mall
well the beow didn't apparently threaten
any people its history of having been in
neighborhoods getting relocated and then
coming back meant the conservation
officer service made the decision to
kill it when these bars get to a point
that the food conditioning the threat of
the public is too high we will have to
do our
job that Langley bear is among the more
than 150 that the conservation officer
service is estimated to have killed so
far this year a number that's likely
higher than previous years get away from
the front door in August alone they got
6,000 black bear related calls across
the province no one is sure why there
refuseed to be a higher level of human
bear contact but there are some theories
we do have a high black bear population
and as Winter's get warmer I you know
this just some some thoughts that that
the Bears are are are doing well um
they're having the two three4 cups and
and the population is not going down
come on you got to go you got to go Bud
so there are more black bears and also
more people as the human population
grows given the geography of British
Colombia where there's a new Housing
Development there's a good chance it's
in bare territory Paul Johnson Global
News minimum wage workers in six
provinces are getting a raise starting
today but in many regions there remains
a wide gap between the minimum wage and
a living wage Megan King has the details
if you work full-time you should should
not be in working
poverty as the cost of living continues
to sky rocket across the country many
provinces are implementing minimum wage
increases as October begins begins while
there were no changes to minimum wage
rates in the territories six of Canada's
10 provinces are raising their minimum
wage New Finland and Labrador Prince
Edward Island and Nova Scotia are all
increasing hourly rates to
$15 ontarios is rising 6.8% to
$16.55 an hour Manitoba's minimum wage
is up more than a dollar to 1530 while
Saskatchewan is up to $14 an hour the
lowest in the country as it stands now
we're several dollars below what it
would take to actually have a living
wage in saskat while Saskatchewan has
indicated the federal minimum wage will
rise again in October 2024 to $15 per
hour local Advocates say it's still a
long way from a livable wage we don't
think that uh this increase in the
minimum wage is going to make the
difference that really we need to have a
plan in place to get us up
to what an actual living wage would be
nowhere in both the province and really
the country can you make a living pay
your bills make ends meet while working
full-time earning a minimum wage even
after these increases on the East Coast
Justice for workers Nova Scotia member
Susan mcneel says the minimum wage needs
to reflect growing expenses people have
to work longer hours like in excess of
40 hours a week and you know have more
than one job just so just so they can
make ends need and even then that is a
struggle Advocates are calling for
minimum wages to match the livable wage
for a region ensuring workers are paid
enough to make ends meet Megan King
Global
News Washington is dealing with its own
Financial pressures a government
shutdown was barely averted before the
midnight deadline this morning but the
deal did not include funding for Ukraine
and it may also end up costing the
Republican house Speaker his job Britney
Rosen joins us from Capitol Hill
Britney Jeff a government shutdown was
looking inevitable that is up until
yesterday when members of Congress here
on Capitol Hill worked into the late
evening hours to pass legislation that
will keep the government open for
another 45 days Kevin McCarthy likely
cutting a deal with the Democrats in
order to pass that bill and as a result
his future as Speaker of the House now
looks uncertain the bill is passed with
a vote of 335 to 91 the House of
Representatives erupts in Applause as
bipartisan spending legislation is
passed on the eve of a government
shutdown the bill is passed the bill was
quickly drafted and sent to the Senate
where it also passed with just hours to
spare and with the stroke of a pen from
US President Joe Biden the legislation
was put into motion a government
shutdown averted shouldn't have gotten
here in the first place it's been a a
day full of twists and turns but the
American people can breathe a sigh of
relief house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
likely cut a deal with Democrats to push
the legislation through Saturday evening
a move that could cost him his
speakership at this time next week Kevin
McCarthy is still speaker of the house
it will because be because the Democrats
bailed him out and he can be their
speaker not mine he says he's coming for
you can you survive yes I'll survive you
know this is personal with Matt Bring It
On Let's get over with it the short-term
spending bill passed Saturday does not
include any new aid for Ukraine
something the White House has said is
concerning but there is hope that will
change in the coming months I'm
confident the Senate will pass further
urgent assistance to Ukraine later this
year though Biden hinted Sunday
Democrats may have reached a deal with
Republicans on support for ke we're
going to get it done I can't believe
those who have voted for supporting
Ukraine overwhelming majority in the
House and Senate Democrat and Republican
will for Pure political reasons let more
people die needlessly in Ukraine
Congress now has until November 17th to
pass permanent legislation to keep the
government open Jeff Britney Rosen in
Washington thanks
Britney manitobans go to the polls this
Tuesday the election will be historic
for one of two reasons it will either
see the first woman lead the progressive
conservatives to a general election
victory in that Province or if the NDP
prevails the first first nation's person
in Canadian history will become premier
of a province Global's Chief political
correspondent David Aken has a preview
how do you do I'm wob Cano and I'm
running to be your Premier it is the
opening line Manitoba NDP leader wob
Cano has used throughout the campaign
that wraps up Tuesday a campaign that
canoe has a better than good chance of
winning using a formula new Democrats in
the west have relied on for decades when
we see the kind of momentum that the NDP
has in Manitoba right now um it's been a
great example of where the party
listened to working people who said the
cost of living and affordability are the
top things on our mind the campaigns
that are most often successful are the
ones that put voters at the center of
their story and they meet voters where
they are Western new Democrats though
have a luxury that Federal NDP leader
jug meet Singh and other Eastern new
Democrats do not have liberal parties
are nearly non-existent in the west
federally uh the main IDE olcal
opposition to the NP is the conservative
party but the main political competition
is the liberal party so it creates that
weird dynamic where you know a lot of
new democrat voters uh want to vote
against conservatives and a lot of new
democrat voters are looking at liberals
as the way to stop the conservatives
there's no question that the new
Democrats who are in the west have a
have a strong history of pragmatic
campaigning and governance and and I
think that you're seeing that carried
through here if canoe wins the NDP will
be in power in Manitoba and N BC in
Alberta the NDP have a strong opposition
and a former Premier in Rachel notley
Saskatchewan NDP leader Carla Beck has
led the official opposition to Premier
Scott Mo for just over a year four
Western provinces where new Democrats
not Liberals are the alternative to
conservative parties are you ready to
stick a fork in the PC
government with that kind of success
Western new Democrats can sometimes be
frustrated that the federal party does
not listen as closely as it might to
Western voices the NDP Accord with the
liberal government is deeply deeply
unpopular in the west and that is in
part because the NDP the federal NDP
spends so little time out here selling
it now a federal party leader like jug
me Singh has lots on his plate and of
course Quebec and Ontario can't be
ignored but if the NDP do well here in
Manitoba next week it'll be another
reminder to their Federal cousins that
the West is where it's at Jeff David
Aken in Winnipeg thanks
David the hockey world is mourning the
loss of Chris snow the assistant general
manager of the Calgary Flames he died of
complications from ALS his wife Kelsey
confirmed the news on social media
writing today we hugged Chris for the
last time as he went to give four people
The Gift of Life by donating his kidneys
liver and lungs snow was diagnosed with
the disease back in 2019 and was
initially given just one year to live
but he continued working for the Flames
while also becoming an advocate for ALS
research over the last four years Chris
snow was 42 years
old coming up ending military aid for
Ukraine why Slovakia's election result
has NATO leaders
worried at least 13 people people are
dead after a fire at a nightclub in
Southeastern Spain authorities say the
blaze broke out in the University City
of meria early this morning Rescuers are
searching for several others who believe
to be missing but the collapse of the
building's roof is making the search for
victims difficult the cause of the fire
is now under
investigation Slovakia held elections
Saturday and the result risks
jeopardizing Ukraine's efforts to repel
Russia's Invasion Robert fito's populist
party is now expected to form a
government alongside Coalition partners
he's also pledged to end all military
aid to Ukraine neighboring NATO member
Poland also recently threatened to stop
sending arms Redman Shannon looks at the
troubling trend for
keev Robert fito looks set to return as
Slovac prime minister having served
twice previously but on those occasions
a neighboring Nation wasn't at
War the morning after his election win
he told reporters his position on
Ukraine is unchanged that Slovakia has
bigger problems a reference to his
election promise not to send a single
extra round of ammunition to keev
instead he wants peace talks in the past
year and a half Slovakia committed
around $1 billion dollar Canadian in
military aid including 13 fighter jets
per capita that's about three times as
much as
Canada Slovakia's election was not just
fought on Ukraine War but on the culture
wars and immigration too fito referring
to environmentalism and lgbtq2 rights as
liberal fascism we think it's bad news
for the country and it will be even
worse news if uh mrito forms a
government many NATO leaders will likely
think the same as they look to send more
arms to keev but Victor Orban in
neighboring Hungary has refused to do so
throughout Russia's Invasion and last
month Poland's government said it may
stop unless a dispute over grain Imports
is resolved I'm confident that Ukraine
and Poland will find a way to to address
those issues I expect bigger problems if
if major European power powers or United
States itself starts to have a second
thought European political analyst Yan
jalona says as long as the Democrats are
in power in Washington smaller NATO
countries can be persuaded to tow the
line before then fito has to woo
Coalition Partners his biggest likely
Ally a supporter of sending weapons to
Ukraine across Slovakia's northern
border this polish opposition rally in
waro comes just two weeks before Poland
goes to the polls a vote that will now
be watched all the more closely in keev
Redmond Channon Global News
London still ahead economic
reconciliation the proposed project that
set to be become one of the largest
indigenous-led industrial developments
in Canadian
history welcome back on the heels of
national Truth and Reconciliation day a
BC first nation is hoping to advance
what's been dubbed economic
reconciliation specifically a proposed
indigenous Le liquefied natural gas
project as Neu garer reports members of
the nisca nation hope it unlocks new
opportunities for future
Generations the lands of Nisa Nation are
rugged beautiful and ready for what
local leaders call economic
reconciliation economic reconciliation
to me is the ability for us to make
those decisions for ourselves nisca
leaders have taken the lead on a
liquefied natural gas project that would
be one of the most significant
indigenous Le industrial developments in
Canadian history I had so much pride in
our because of our leadership and what
they did like past leaders he says it's
a continuation of the work of previous
generations after Decades of being
ignored in resource development on their
own land there was about $13 billion in
forestry that was taken out of our
Valley and we didn't see a dime of that
the 10 billion export facility in
Northwest BC has been green lit to enter
the province's environmental review
process with a Consortium of Canadian
gas producers
and it's not the only major project in
the region the BC government also gave
final approval to the 22 billion doll
heisa Nation Cedar LNG project I haven't
really seen the BC government support uh
economic gr installation today I mean
really First Nations are the ones asking
for LG development to take place at a at
a much faster Pace but critics say
tapping into the Region's natural gas
reserves for overseas these exports will
increase emissions and the idea faces
opposition from some First Nations which
is the common and biggest concern about
natural gas plants is that you have to
burn gas to run them we have electrical
barges that will power it until
electricy can be delivered to the site
so be Net Zero ready is part of the plan
it'll be Net Zero ready the moment we're
ready to start we'll be ready to begin
the operation by 2030 with an eye on
making the project as environmentally
sustain able as possible indigenous
leaders are pushing ahead it gives us
the opportunity to address housing
issues to address poverty and it just
puts us in a great position to make
those own decisions and they say it's a
key opportunity for True Independence
and generational change that's what it
means for me is that we reconcile with
the economy of Canada that we're no
longer Outsiders looking in but part of
it Nara Global News Nisa Nation
[Music]
Sydney Crosby hit the ice in his
hometown of Cole Harbor Nova Scotia his
Pittsburgh Penguins held an open
practice ahead of a preseason game
against Ottawa it's Crosby's first game
there in over a decade and that is
global national for this Sunday night
I'm Jeff simple tonight's your Canada is
the point Prim Lighthouse near Belfast
Prince Edward Island thanks for watching
have a great
night
[Music]